uh
and then we show you some stuff that
we've been doing on how to monitor apis
uh with uh with node and uh this
this thing called this open source
framework called frisbee.js
it's running jasmine it's kind of like a
unit testing kind of deal
um so what this session is you know
trying to get feedback from you guys
and see how you guys monitor api so
let's say we were to create some apis
and how do you monitor it um
i'll show you some of the ideas that
we've been having
i just want to kind of curious enlarge
what you guys
been doing like when you deploy apis
like how do you even monitor that kind
of stuff
um so really i think one of the problem
is
apis are just proliferating and they're
everywhere like
even the applications that we've been
creating um in the last
year or two it's just really api driven
so for example uh we would usually
create like an api front end first right
like so all
authentication everything like user
creation uh editing those will all be
served out as an api um and even like
internal stuff like authentication like
internally we would be using api
uh we've been using a lot of stuff from
uh like
premade servers such as i don't know
have you ever heard of like openstack
keystone
so what openstack keystone is it's kind
of like an orchestration software for
well openstack is orchestration software
for cloud
and they really modulized it so keystone
is uh one of the
services that their open source project
provides which is
um just authentication and user creation
um
and things like that so some of the
projects that we've been doing was like
we would just spin up that server and it
would provide you all the functionality
via api
already so then we would internally use
that for user management so
it would create your users you could
update users
change passwords get authentication
tokens
uh for a short period time long period
of time whatever you want
um so that we didn't really have to
rewrite all of that code for all the
different various projects that we made
yeah so and so this talk i didn't really
want to i wanted to focus about the
thing uh but
uh so we're actually so lincoln and i we
are working on this project called auto
dev bot
okay um gotcha i said no problem no
problem
but i yeah for this talk i really wanted
to take out
the company from it so i didn't really
want to sit here and pitch you
on like autodevbot what we're doing i
didn't want to sell you anything
i just wanted to talk about like the
idea but yeah so
uh really what we're hosting is auto
deadbot
and this is really what well i don't
want to go into that i don't want to
persuade you guys either
way or another of what we're doing
um so yeah so what we've been seeing is
like just
and when i say we also it's the last
two years uh i've been uh
starting this company called
algorithms.i o uh we subsequently sold
it
in november um it was a machine learning
as a service uh platform in the cloud
and that was pretty much all served up
via apis
then so this slide is from mastery so we
kind of had
an architecture like this right uh you
have
um kind of user facing
apis so you might have like
shipping and crms and then you might
have
internal apis uh that different teams
are making right uh
like you would have accounts you have
inventory you might have payroll
so like basically what this is kind of
describing is
different departments or teams creating
apis
to serve internal needs
so one of the internal needs might be
like inventory like what kind of
inventory do i have
in my company and that's all
served up via api internally so
other departments in that company can
utilize that however they want
the website front end might utilize that
to put
if there's availability and things like
that on the website for a certain
product
internal users might do you know
hit that api for accounting purposes
and other purposes right so um i'm not
sure if you guys are seeing this
but i'm definitely seeing this where
even in larger corporations
people are generally just creating
api as the base layer and letting other
people consume their apis
so i'm not sure if you guys been seeing
that but i've definitely
been seeing that a lot and it makes it a
lot
easier to kind of grow from that because
you're just
delivering generic apis out to
your user base and if when they ask for
something so
you tend not to create like gui type
interfaces
and you leave the gui type interfaces to
the end consumer
team for them to create on however they
want to
consume these apis all right
um so one of the problems that we've
been finding
um so we as in autodevot and
uh even last year when i was at
algorithms.i o was that
uh how do you monitor all these api once
we push into production so my role uh at
algonquin io last year was
developer and kind of devops operation
guy um so it was a small team of uh like
five people
and we had about uh we were on amazon
and
you know it would go up and down to
about like 50 servers or so
so in production mode um and then we had
development and staging environments
uh which had about five servers for the
staging and
qa environment and in the production it
was
one of the problem was like how do we
monitor all this stuff because
what we were creating was basically
uh something that looked very similar to
this uh you know you renamed the boxes
to different things
and it looked very similar like one guy
would create
this you know this box that would serve
out some apis
so what we were doing was machine
learning uh so these
were like workers that crunched some
data
and there were other boxes that were
consuming streams of
information in as you know as a rest api
and the problem was uh once we pushed
this out
into production it was like how do you
monitor this and how do you make sure
it worked because we had a semi uh
continuous deployment system that we're
deploying code into these various boxes
right
as once it gets through some certain
gates
it would automatically deploy into these
boxes and how do we do this integration
testing
to make sure it works so there are tools
like that so we use tools like pingdom
uptime robot and there are tools that
are really really similar to pingdom
like
monitors and alert site which are
basically
a monitors website so you go into the
web gui
you punch in a url you say i want to put
i want to get
i want to post you give it some data
and you know it'll go out and reach out
like if you know if you're familiar with
it like curl calls right
it'll reach out to that url that you
specify
and it would grab that url
and make sure that whatever response
that you thought
you want it and it'll make sure that it
was there and if it wasn't it would like
email you or
hit another url for like a web hook to
page of duty or something like that
but the problem with that was that uh it
was gooey driven
and it was it was really hard to
automate they really didn't have an api
that says hey i want to create this
new test um to monitor my new api
that you know that i've done you really
had to just go into the gui and punch
all this stuff
in manually um so the problem was really
uh creating new stuff and then updating
uh other stuff right like so like if the
api changed
um i had to manually go in here and
edit these uh from the web gui which
kind of sucks
because then you end up having you know
like 30 40 50 tests
and it's like how do you even keep track
of that no web services
you had to go into gui so yeah so that
really sucked like that was the problem
like i would be
perfectly fine with using pingdom with
time robot if
hey there was an api uh
but the other problem really was that
uh this thing was kind of siloed
into uh your operations thing too like
your development qa would not be using
this thing
i suppose if you did automate it you can
have your qa
and development use it but they tend not
to use
stuff like this right like i'm not sure
you know how how many people in here are
developers
everybody like i don't know if you guys
use like pingdom
like you guys would want to use pingdom
to monitor
you know a codebase that you were like
actively working on
like i don't think that really makes too
much sense but
um so really like
there was no good devops tool um
so devops is really the merging of
development operations skill sets
uh so that you can kind of highly
automate environments right like so
stuff like uh amazon uh there's apis for
amazon
you could scale up and down you could
create environments you could destroy
environments
um you could go as far as you know
automatically deploying
a new environment for every build you
want or you know
to something in between that
um and devops groups really don't want
to run infrastructure
uh they've been tending to uh
use services as much as they can so kind
of the rise of like tools
like pagerduty new relic
scout and a whole slew of other tools
like app dynamic
for you know application performance
metrics um so i don't know how many of
you guys use
new relic in here here's a new relic
you what
but did it give you more information
than you had before
of your application
okay or how about even like database
queries like
one cool thing was like okay cool now
like
every single database call
that i'm doing if i tool it be before
and after
like i can see every single database
call that i'm making and how long it's
making
and if there was one out of whack thing
that some guy makes some super duper
query
that like took like 30 seconds to run
then we you know we that would actually
automatically
pop up right we can be like hey dude
like you got to optimize this query a
little bit
um we can't be having you know users sit
there for like over 30 seconds waiting
for
stuff um which was cool
um so really like where are the tools
for kind of devops generation so this
was actually came from another slide
deck that we've been doing
let me skip over to this
so what we've actually been doing was
using
open source frameworks testing
frameworks
for not only testing our code in
development and qa
but we've been using it in production
too
so we will run the same rest api tests
in development while we're creating it
and then qa guys would be running the
same stuff just to make sure
it works developers would be creating
these kind of
api risk api unit tests
the qa guys would be extending that for
their side use cases because you know qa
guys like to break stuff and they're
like
well what if i threw this information
into the api
uh like these weird characters or make
these weird calls you know
is your api still working um
and then what we've been doing uh even
for the last company for algorithms io
was that
we were using the same tests and running
it against the production system
to make sure that pretty much the
system test was working so these these
open source you know we were running
frisbee.js
and so here goes a frisbee digest let me
go over this a little bit
uh so it's really it's all it's based on
jasmine and jasmine is a unit testing
framework for
node.js and frisbee.js kind of is on top
of that
which puts another layer on top of
jasmine that kind of
is more is dedicated and focused to rest
api
testing like to build rest api tests
so it has structures like you can create
and name it and you'd want to do a get
on this url uh then you start expecting
stuff right like i think
all this expect stuff um
is really unit testy but for frisbee
it has these methods that um expect
certain things and it's looking for
certain headers
right so like this one expecting a
header status of
200 back from whatever you're calling it
and this one's expecting that header
contains
you know content type application json
uh then you can start expecting stuff in
the body
uh like json types uh username a field
call username and this field is a string
or this field that's a boolean age which
is a number
and it just tosses everything else
so we've been writing these tests
uh for in development and qa
for a long time now the fact maybe like
a year and a half almost two
um then when we start deploying the
code into production
we were like well how do we know this
works because we found stuff where
one api was upgraded and another api
wasn't um and it just wasn't working and
somehow it gets through
you know staging and qa or sometime
in the beginning like the deployment
scripts were kind of
not so great so it would kind of deploy
into some boxes and not deploying other
boxes
so you had kind of weird cluster state
kind of going on
um and we were just kind of struggling
on how to monitor
uh the production cluster
all right so creating a lot of the
pingdom
stuff was just really manual and just
took a long time
and it just kind of became
unmaintainable over time so that's what
we did in the beginning
but it just really became unmaintainable
you know in the long run we had to go
through every single one to make sure it
was still cool
or we would add new ones or it would
delete new ones and then we finally
thought like
hey why don't we just run the rest api
test that we're making
in development in qa and run that
against
production and
what this gave us was really that uh it
gave us a lot
better test coverage than what pingdom
and other stuff that we were making
solely for the production network
um this was you know we had you know
hundreds of these tests
so like the cover was just
way better and the coverage uh
was actually maintained right like it
went through a life cycle where
uh you know if you were to touch this
api
um you would most likely edit
these tests first and then go and
do whatever you were going to go do to
your api if you were changing the
outputs or the inputs of this api
you probably go edit these tests first
and then go mess with your code
to say okay cool now i'm going to return
this new field or like now we have this
new field that we're picking off from
the database and returning it
so these were actually maintained a
whole lot better
than you know trying to do this in like
pingdom or
uptime robot um
so really oh go ahead did you guys like
your own like email notification
uh so we used page of duty yeah yeah so
uh yeah we didn't want to build any of
that right
um and so we just used
pagerduty um to plug it into this so we
just had it
continuously running um and if this
thing
through errors uh it would just make a
call out
with quick quick call you know curl call
out to a pager duties api
um and then that would then we'll use
that for alerting
so that yeah that's good for like
suppression like if it
continuously failed it you know
pagerduty is good for like suppression
like so i won't be getting
a hundred emails you know every minute
an
email i'll suppress it and it'll
escalate all that
and do all that good stuff right um
so yeah so i mean like i want to kind of
open it up and see
what you guys thought um would you guys
do this is this crazy
or is it what about the effects on the
production data
yep yep so that's a good question so
yeah definitely we didn't run
the full suite uh there was another
branch that we actually ran that had
the good tests like so some of the
destructive stuff
um we didn't run so a lot of the stuff
that was destructive
against um for example
uh like deleting
some data sets that our test depends on
um that were large we didn't do that
kind of stuff
um so and some of the internal
apis were um you know
disabling users and things like that we
didn't do so there was definitely
another branch that
was the good test and we're like okay
cool we're
we're happy to run this against
production
and so we think that's not going to
break production so yeah like
what about reproducible state i mean
typically you set up tests you you set a
base state of the system
i'm thinking of old school perhaps um is
uh these
uh api staples where you've got to kind
of kick them off in a starting stage
that you confirm
they transition yeah
and it's not like unit tests either
where like i'm
pre-processing stuff like i'm not like
dumping the database and
putting into a state that i want and
then running my
unit tests against it um so this is
definitely
yeah so we definitely have to think
about running this against production
where
um we never you know
we're pretty confident on how like let's
say a database right like how the user's
table
is set up we never dumped the user tape
you know in production to run a test
so all the tests in the branch were
tests that were good to go that were
saying
if a user were to run the
you know call this command against the
api it should return
x y and z um so it's a little different
than
you know straight unit testing we were
doing
but not like
not a hundred percent different right
like we would take maybe like 30
out of this thing i don't know if that
answer your questions
it seems does it also give you latency
it does it does so yeah so like uh
this gives you all the metrics so it
puts out um
you know regular kind of like junit
test xmls and stuff like that where you
can use that and feed it into your
integration system also
so we you you know so we use this in
jenkins and you know have jenkins
run this in uh on
on the development builds and the qa
builds right um
so yes it has all the it has all the
latencies and things like that um for
every single call
which is good but i'm not sure yeah so
we didn't really use it for that like uh
well back then new relic wasn't really
there but then we had other metrics for
like api latencies and things like that
but
you certainly can use it for that if you
wanted to definitely
so yeah let me ask you guys like and
you're
you know how many people work for like a
startup over here
are they over 40 people
under 40 people
do you guys interact with like the
operations team
and how's that working how is that like
that does that solve every single need
that you have for monitoring apis
i mean it definitely solves you know
your apis are down
it doesn't solve the case of you know
are all apis
returning what they're supposed to be
returning yeah you know
we've definitely had issues where like
we updated api everything looks good and
then a customer is like hey this field
is not there anymore and it's crazy
yep yes yeah so i think we need
something like this
and then so this case right now like how
do you
handle that case or you just don't um
yeah we just try to be a lot more
diligent about it but yeah i mean it
just hasn't been um
critical enough i guess it's to sort of
bubble up into something
so they need to do something like this
but okay okay
and then uh are you guys like assuming
that since you're
coming to these meetups you guys are
writing like no js
stuff uh that idea is actually opening
the job
okay guys for some other stuff but not
for
the api portion of the company okay
yeah and curious uh so like
for unit testing what do you guys use
junit yep and then for testing like the
rest apis
unit for that also yep um you can like
mock up
all the like requests and all this other
stuff
java libraries for that yep yep got to
and then on the note side doing
and would you guys would you like
i think you guys could do the same thing
like let's say like would you guys run a
subset of those
junit tests to test your api
yeah ideally that would that would be
that i mean we also kind of run that
before we push to
push the production so i don't know if
that wouldn't necessarily cost the case
or that guy's
got yeah yeah but i'm thinking you
probably have a
unit test case now for that very thing
okay good yeah yeah
yeah um yeah so i don't know if you guys
would want to see
more of um
sit here so yeah so we've been using
frisbee
js so we've been writing a lot of node
stuff and
um just in general there's been using a
lot of frisbee
js stuff um
can you get nested in the
tights uh you can you can and then one
of
yeah you get you definitely can like if
you had a json like a json right like
you get
json
yep yep yep and in this array
you can actually say you know like you
don't really
care how homies in the array you can go
through every single
array spot and check for structure
integrity of what's in there also
so let's see can i find the
so one weird thing about node.js is
really that you know
since it's um async
that your tests might run
a little funny
your test just kind of runs funny right
i mean like uh so all this
stuff is async it'll run all at the same
time so
some of the problems that we've been
running into um
uh some of the stuff that we've been
just running into was um
was that uh usually you would have to
authenticate um
before you did anything right so there's
a setup
usually there's a set of public function
for the api
that you can just hit without any
authentication which is cool if you're
you know for async stuff right like you
just
hit that all and you're cool but there
are some stuff that
uh you need all you need to authenticate
first
before you subsequently you know use
that authentication token
um in the subsequent call so that's the
only
kind of you know funny thing about um
these tests is that you would kind of
have to nest it
um trying to find the
so really they built in this
um after json uh
function where this would be called
um then subsequently anything that's in
this block would be called
that's that's like the pattern for most
of our kind of unit tests where
um we would authenticate for this other
case stuff we'll authenticate
and then get the token back and then
use that token to like say update a
user's info
for that current user you know like
delete the tokens and stuff like that um
so that was kind of funny thing
you know well i guess not funny but i
mean that's just kind of the way that
node.js works since it's you know
asynchronous in nature
um but yeah so
that was really my whole talk here